مستشفى ثوب الجامعي التابع لجامعه الخرطوم
احد اكبر المستشفيات الرئيسيه في السودان
يبدو فارغا من المرضى منذ اول ايام الحرب
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بات عاجزا عن تقديم خدماته للمرضى بل
يفتقر الى ادنى مقومات استمراره نحن اصلا
كلها اطفال
وغسلوا لسبب لانه ما عندنا المواد من
اختبار الاطفال انتهت وفي السودان عموما
ما في
هنا غرفه العمليات تبدو مهجوره وتعاني
الاهمال اذ تم اجراء اخر عمليه فيها يوم
اندلاع الحرب لطفل عمره شهر واحد بعد ذلك
غادر كادرها الطبي انا نجد منظمات
منظمات حقوق الانسان الدوليه والاقليميه
والمحليه
ورجال البر والاحسان
ان يقفوا على الشعب السوداني ويقفوا
بالزاد مع مستشفى ثوب لان المستشفى هي
سليمه من كل النواحي ما فيها دمار ما فيها
خراب ما فيها الامن فيها تمام لكن لا يوجد
فيها كوادر طبيه ولا يوجد فيها ادويه جميع
اقسام المستشفى باتت مغلقه وليس بمقدورها
استقبال المرضى في ظل ظروف امنيه معقده
الا من خدمات غسل الكلان الكبار فقط لكنهم
يواجهون صعوبات في الوصول الى المستشفى
بسبب انعدام الامن والمال احيانا الطريق
ما امن
الغسل
بقروش كذا يعني
تخلي اولادك بدون مصاريف عشان تجي تغسلي
كذا معانات هؤلاء تبدو مستمره ما دامت
الحرب لم تضع اوزارها بعد
معاناه لا تقتصر على هذا المستشفى فحسب
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء فان اكثر
من 60 مستشفى متاخمه لمناطق القتال في
البلاد من اصل نحو 90 مستشفى باتت خارج
الخدمه بشكل كامل
قسم غسل الكلى هو الوحيد الذي يعمل في
المستشفى لكنه يعاني من نقص الكوادر
والمستلزمات الطبيه ويظل مجرد وصول المرضى
الى المستشفى مخاطره مع استمرار الحرب
اسامه سيدي احمد الجزيره من داخل مستشفى
سوبل الجامعي جنوبي الخرطوم